the following table lists the values of
functions f and g and of their
derivatives f prime and g prime for the
x values negative 2 and 4. and so you
can see for x equals negative 2 x equals
4 they give us the values of f g f prime
and g prime
let function capital f be defined as the
composition of f and g it's lower case f
of g of x and they want us to evaluate f
prime of 4.
so you might immediately recognize that
if i have a function that can be viewed
as the composition of other functions
that the chain rule will apply here and
so and i'm just going to restate the
chain rule the derivative of capital f
is going to be the derivative of
lowercase f the outside function with
respect to the inside function
so
lowercase f prime of g of x
times the derivative of the inside
function with respect to x
times g prime of x
and if we're looking for f prime of 4 f
prime of 4
well everywhere we see an x we replace
it with a 4. that's going to be
lowercase f prime
of g
of 4
times g prime
of 4. now how do we figure this out they
haven't given us explicitly the values
of the functions on for all x's but
they've given it to us at some
interesting points so the first thing
you might want to figure out is well
what is g of 4 going to be
well they tell us when x is equal to 4 g
of 4 is negative 2. this tells us that
the value that g of x takes on when x is
equal to 4 is negative 2. so this right
over here is negative 2.
and so this first part is f prime of
negative 2. so what is f prime
what is f prime of negative 2
well when x is equal to negative 2
f prime is equal to one
so this right over here is f prime of
negative two that is equal to one
and now we just have to figure out what
g prime of four is
well when let me circle this g prime of
4 when x is equal to 4 and i'll scroll
down a little bit
when x is equal to 4 g prime takes on
the value 8.
so there you have it f prime of 4 is
equal to 1 times 8 which is equal to
eight and we're done